I'm kind of a big deal when it comes to
the Nobel Prize at least in my own house
I've written two books with the words
Nobel Prize in the title first one
losing the Nobel Prize was about my
Memoir as a young scientist trying to
Aspire to a greatest Accolade in the
scientific world the second comes from
my interviews on this very Channel with
nine Nobel laureates about their wisdom
not just their knowledge it's useful to
us and getting into sync with the world
and understanding it and harmonizing
with it and being able to cope with it
and today we're talking about a
scientist who had tons and tons of
knowledge but relatively little wisdom
and I call it the worst Nobel Prize ever
there have been several controversial
Nobel prizes some say the worst Nobel
Prize ever was actually the one given
for the lobotomy they kept being wrong
sometimes we're not going to talk about
that on this channel we like to preserve
our brains here true as that may be
there have been actual blunder Nobel
prizes Real Bloopers when you think
about Gustav dalen shown here who won
the Nobel Prize in 1912 for his
invention of gas accumulators for use in
lighthouses and buoys now who Among Us
doesn't use a lighthouse to get around
and navigate their way through life I
know I sure do forget that newfangled
GPS system as silly as that Nobel Prize
was and actually it maybe was of
Interest back in 1912 or so however I
remind you that was just seven years
after Albert Einstein invented the
special theory of relativity
photoelectric effect brownie in motion
many other things for which he wouldn't
win snowball prize for another 17 years
he won the 1921 Nobel Prize but
the land got his number
good old Albert why is that well for one
reason there was some anti-Semitism with
the Nobel Prize selection committee and
that's plagued the Nobel Prize for over
a hundred years it's gotten better and
there have been a lot of Jewish Nobel
Prize winners today but there's still
possible discrimination and issues with
the Nobel Prize that almost every one of
the Nobel Prize winners that I've
interviewed has admitted to that the
Nobel Prize needs reform some of which
was included in my first book losing the
Nobel Prize now let's turn to haber's
Nobel Prize who was for Tabor what did
he do he's been called the man that
killed Millions but saved billions
what's a few million people when you
save a few billion people is that really
true would the world have actually
played out differently if Fritz didn't
invent the process that we're about to
explore who knows it's called
counterfactual history it's not really
that interesting to speculate on but I
assume like most scientific discoveries
it would have been covered eventually
and perhaps without his immoral and
anti-wisdom type Behavior now I've done
a video on this channel called knowledge
is not equal to wisdom and I've also
done a video at Prager University called
follow the science where I get into some
of these same issues science has to be
first and always about pursuing
knowledge we have a tendency to conflate
knowledge with wisdom when someone's
incredibly smart we think that they're
also quite wise there's almost no
correlation between them Fritz Haber was
a chemist and he was a German Jewish
chemist and that's important for reasons
you'll see soon he was the co-inventor
along with Bosch of the so-called Haber
Bosch process and it's that same Bosh
that later went on to create things in
the German industrial complex operating
from the early to the middle of the 20th
century what is the Haber Bosch process
well you benefited from it earlier today
when you had breakfast you see their
Discovery led to the process of
fertilizer production that we enjoy and
almost all of the food that we eat it's
one of the most important inventions or
discoveries in modern history and fits
well with what Alfred Nobel wanted when
he created the Nobel Prize via his death
in 1896 his will written in 1895 mental
note make your will out at least the day
before you die his will said that the
prize should go to a scientist who
discovers or in events something that
has the greatest benefit to Mankind and
that was discovered in the preceding
year by a single person again these are
rules that the modern Nobel Prize
committee ignores routinely but yet
again see my book losing a Nobel Prize
for more details this fertilizer
production method is responsible for
almost half of the food that we eat on
Earth and so it led to the 1918 Nobel
prizes and it's controversial but not
for the scientific reasons that say the
Bohr atomic hypothesis shown here is
responsible for controversy because that
model is actually wrong the atom isn't
like a little tiny solar system so
although it makes predictions that are
correct the actual model on which it's
based is completely wrong as we now know
so it's different than that type of a
blunder or mistake by the Nobel Prize
Committee just a quick pause to ask you
for a small favor while my thumb is
occupied with old Albert on it yours is
presumably freed up to leave a thumbs up
on this video really helps me a lot with
a good old-fashioned YouTube algorithm
thanks a lot now back to the video let's
take a step back we're used to talking
about physics on this channel so botany
is not my strongest suit in fact when I
would do biological experiments in high
school I would say be given a frog I
would do the dissection but I was so bad
at it the Frog would live plants are the
backbone of all life on Earth because
everything traces its energy source to a
plant at some level or another and of
course the plants Trace their energy
source to the sun which we talked about
so there is a connection between what I
do as an astronomer and some of these
Botanical Delights that we're going to
talk about plants need more than just
water and carbon dioxide they need
nitrogen now the air is full of it so
you might think well I'll just grab it
from the air that's not so easy to do
the nitrogen in turn forms part of the
DNA structure that is so crucial to all
living systems DNA in turn is built from
amino acids which require nitrogen so
without nitrogen there's no plants no
plants there's no animal life and we are
not here to be discussing the importance
of nitrogen the role of nitrogen in
chemical processes that affect Botanical
life is described by sources of nitrogen
and sinks of nitrogen things that
replenish nitrogen and things that take
away nitrogen denitrification shown here
is leaching phenomena which then
produces nitrogen dioxide or nitrous
oxide or dinitrogen oxide rather or
molecular nitrogen and two and that then
goes into the atmosphere and the plant
cells also suck up the nitrogen and use
that to build their amino acids which
then produce the organic material that
life forms like you and I will eat
everyone out there is eating a plant at
some level even if you're not a
vegetarian you've given me the food that
my food eats fertilizers can replace the
nitrogen in the soil that gets sucked up
by the plants and you want to keep this
process in Balance the carbon I should
say in the amino acid comes from usually
decomposing plant material that's
already there the green matter that then
decays is responsible for replenishing
the carbon but it doesn't as effectively
re-establish the amount of nitrogen
needed for those same amino acids so if
you're growing a lot of plant life you
need a lot of nitrogen and farming is a
battle between denitrification and
nitrification so getting sources and
sinks of nitrogen can you farm they have
to be in a delicate balance too much
nitrogen can cause problems as well as
too little nitrogen will prevent the
accumulation of the amino acids
necessary for plant life so this can be
done in many ways the ancient agrarian
societies knew that you had to rotate
crops you couldn't keep planting the
same crops in the same place and expect
to get the same Bountiful Cornucopia
Harvest crop rotation isn't fully as
efficient as actually fertilizing is but
you do have to do both of them and of
course you can have composting where you
take manure from animals
which has some nitrogen but mostly it's
carbon it's the unprocessed food from
the ruminants that don't get converted
to beef or milk or whatever they're
producing and so that goes back to the
soil but again it doesn't have as much
nitrogen it might have phosphine
phosphorus and carbon but it doesn't
have nitrogen imagine is the key for
sustaining a planet with 8 billion
people on it populations been growing
exponentially from just about a billion
or so in haber's time to the 8 billion
number that we have today so where are
we going to get this nitrogen from there
are sources of natural fertilizers fun
fact bad guano bat droppings
can still be used by each and every
red-blooded American citizen as a source
to harvest for fertilization purposes
look into that on your own I don't want
to be accused of even being more bat
crazy than I already am now air is 20
nitrogen let's just use that right no no
nitrogen triple bonds as Illustrated in
this chemical equation here is
incredibly stable and very difficult to
break into just single nitrogen atoms
Atomic nitrogen what about making
ammonia well making ammonia is very
simple you just take two nitrogen atoms
bound together as molecular nitrogen and
two you add three Atomic hydrogen
molecules H2 and you get out two
molecules of ammonia NH3 the formula to
make ammonia could be extremely simple
but the problem is it's very slow and
that's because also ammonia is somewhat
stable as well as molecular nitrogen so
this is where good old Fritz enters the
story he was a German Jewish chemist
working in the 19th century in the 20th
century
fixated you might say on producing
ammonia and for his work eventually and
what was known as the Haber Bosch
process he did win the 1918 Nobel Prize
what is it how does it work let's do
some chemistry shall we haber's idea was
to take the exothermic nature of making
ammonia and use it to an advantage to
effectively recycle it and use the heat
the exothermic nature means it gives off
heat which you can use energy and you
have to only work on speeding it up once
you have the right ingredients all you
must do is optimize it at least that's
what he figured how can you get gases to
react faster it's actually a form of
molecular physics you can give them more
energy heat them up to higher
temperatures
you can add in more molecules increase
the pressure
you can force the molecules to mix using
shock waves to compress the gas together
and the result is that you get ammonia
out of the reaction chamber you have a
certain number of these cyclical
Chambers and each one processes and
amplifies if you will the process
material from the previous step
and when you have unreacted gas as I
said it's not 100 efficient and it's
also slow you send that ammonia back
into the system and start it over again
again
this is a self-sustaining exothermic
reaction with compression at its core at
high temperatures this is the Haber
Bosch process but not quite what was
really the key enabling catalytic
ingredient was a catalyst a catalyst is
a type of material that doesn't get
consumed in the reaction you may be
familiar with Catalyst from your
catalytic converter which uses Platinum
the main bottleneck in the reaction is
separating the two nitrogen atoms in the
nitrogen two molecule from one another
so that you can make them recycle them
into NH3 remember you get out two NH3
ammonia molecules for every one molecule
of molecular nitrogen so it turns out
that by experimenting with different
types of catalysts mostly different
types of metals from Iron to Nickel
manganese and calcium or tried but the
most effective one was a rare one called
osmium that osmium allowed him to
dramatically enhance and amplify the
production and it didn't require that he
uranium which would have probably killed
him before he finished this process
the Haber Bosch process shown here is
used to make literally 200 million tons
of ammonia every single year
ammonia has wide ranging uses from
fertilizers where it uses mostly 80
percent of the ammonia to explosives to
refrigerant gases and many many uses
the commercialization and efficient
production has led to the feeding of
billions of humans now why is this the
worst Nobel Prize in history according
to Yours Truly well for one thing Haber
wasn't only interested in fertilization
and preserving human lives he used the
fame and money that he got from this
process to bolster his factories his
chemical factories and what he was later
recruited by the axis armies during
World War One when the Axis powers were
fighting the Allied Powers he is
chemical knowledge was used and his
chemical technology was used to create
the very first chemical weapons earning
him the moniker the father of chemical
warfare now this chemical warfare you
might say well maybe that was just uh
you know how they used to fight things
back at the time and did the US use an
atomic bomb well this was actually
outlawed prior to World War one and
signed by Germany so Germany was party
to a treaty that banned the use of
chemical weapons they were so gruesome
and by some estimates tens of thousands
of Americans and British were killed
overseen by not only Fritz Haber but
also five other German chemical shock
troops as they were called All of whom
had won Nobel prizes or would go on to
win Nobel prizes for his work he did win
the Nobel Prize but unfortunately the
fame and financial success that he
obtained was used to further sustain his
chemical Ambitions and later in World
War II haber's family was actually
killed in Nazi concentration camps that
used a chemical called zycon B which had
been produced in factories utilizing
some of haber's own mechanisms so his
party being a party to the Axis powers
in World War One eventually LED not only
to Great tragedy in his family life but
eventually Devastation and destruction
of his own family at the hands of the
Nazi monsters in World War II so never
conflate knowledge with wisdom as the
saying goes knowledge is knowing a
tomato is a fruit but wisdom is knowing
not to put it in a fruit salad and
sometimes the consequences are far far
more grave literally for Humanity so
never conflate knowledge with wisdom if
you'd like to learn more about the Nobel
Prize and conflation of knowledge and
wisdom click here for this playlist that
I made just for you
[Music]